a powerful winter storm is taking aim at
the Northeast this morning blizzard
conditions and more than a foot of snow
are expected in parts of New England the
severe weather is making roads
treacherous people are being told not to
drive some places could see up to two
feet of snow this is the second major
storm in less than a week to hit the
region Don de leurs in portland maine
where snows already been piling up Don
good morning it really has good morning
this huge pile shows you just how much
snow has been coming down and the worst
is yet to come the winds have been so
high it's a bit of a Sisyphean effort on
the part of snow plow operators as soon
as they get the streets clear the winds
blow it all back on again for them for
the tow truck operators and for first
responders it's going to be a long day a
major nor'easter slammed in northern New
York and New England on Sunday just days
after another storm blasted towns and
cities across the northeast wind gusts
of more than 50 miles per hour and as
much as two feet of snow have been
forecast throughout the region Blizzard
like conditions and slick roads caused
several accidents and drivers to slide
off the highway a woman was rescued from
a frozen pond in New Jersey after her
car jumped the curb and crashed to the
ice Don McEwan jumped in to savor in
Portland Maine firefighters spent hours
clearing away an oil tanker truck that
jackknifed on the interstate highway
workers have been working overtime to
keep on top of the fast-moving storm
massachusetts governor Charlie Baker
urged drivers to take caution don't
crowd the plows allow the personnel and
the equipment to keep on doing the work
they're doing to keep the roads clear
outside Boston a 60 year old man was
killed as a plow was backing up in a
hospital parking lot at a Massachusetts
Airport emergency responders rushed to
help five people on board a private
plane that skidded off the runway no one
was injured the hazardous conditions
canceled hundreds of flights into and
out of several major Northeast airports
in fact all flights in and out of
Portland Jetport have been cancelled
since last night they won't resume again
until 8pm Easter tonight because that's
when the bulk of this storm is expected
to move off the coast Nora all right Don
Wow there in the snow thank you